[主播] 大概在1万年前，新月石地，就是现在的两河流域和埃及，幼发拉底底格里斯这里，人类驯化了小麦。
[主播] 所以赫拉利觉得是小麦驯化的人类，而不是人类驯化小麦。因为以前我们学会的直立行走，为了种小麦你弯下腰去。以前你学会的奔跑，你浑身健康，为了种小麦你浑身疾病。
[主播] 大陆的亚洲的另一端，1万年前中国人驯化了水道，所以水道是我们驯化的。
[主播] 人类一共700万年的历史，真正重要的只有这1万年。1万年的历史很久，但我只爱你，你在一起的每一分每一秒，每一招每一息。
[主播] I love three things in the world. 我爱这世间的三个东西。The sun, the moon and you. 太阳、月亮和你。The sun is for the day. The moon is for the night. And you, forever. 太阳是白天，月亮是晚上，你是永远。
[主播] 1万年前人类驯化的水道。
[主播] 我们于是发现了好的东西。
[主播] 但是大家知道真正现在的革命，其实工业革命，我们上天入地，航空母舰，宇宙飞船都是200年。
[主播] 如果说微观到原子的层面，其实我们也是由氢、氧、碳、铁这些组成的。组成你身体的元素可能比你脚下这颗蔚蓝色的星球其实要更为古老。你身体70%是水，氢二氧。
[主播] 氢来自于大爆炸，碳来自于恒星内部的核聚变，铁来自于超新星的爆炸。
[主播] 所以从这个角度去说，我们都是宇宙形成的孩子。刚知道这一点就很浪漫了。每当你觉得自己是一个无名之辈，无足轻重，每当你觉得未来暗淡无光，没有希望的时候，请你记得有7000亿亿亿颗原子只为你一个人而活。
[主播] 如果你身体的DNA连成一条线，你可以从地球一直到冥王星。所以你自己就能完成星际穿越。你很美好。
[主播] 就像顾城的这首诗，我们生如蚁而美如神。请你记住这一点。你不要太灰心丧气。
[主播] 运气不一定一直好，但你的状态要一直好，心态要一直好。我刚讲了人类美若神明，但你要知道微生物更加是地球霸主。
[主播] 如果按照现在科学家们的预计，再10亿年后，地球的温度将会上升10度。上升10度意味着你我都不存在了。但直到那个时候，在北极、南极或者地球第三极的冰层里仍然有超强的细菌。在火山口接近沸腾充满硫磺的水里头仍然有微生物的存在。他们确实很强大。
[主播] 我再跟你讲一讲未来。预计10亿年后，太阳会升温，地球的温度提升10度，到时候人类都会不复存在。
[主播] 就算我们躲过了那一劫，50亿年后，太阳的寿命用尽了，它会坍缩形成黑洞，把太阳系整个吸进去。
[主播] 就算我们逃离了，等到数万亿年之后，不再形成任何一颗新的恒星，整个宇宙中的所有的星系都坍缩成黑洞，就连黑洞也消失之后，最终会形成一个叫Heat Death，叫热寂。没有光，也没有声，黑暗的，冰冷的，什么都没有。
[主播] 你听到这里有一点难过对吧？我第一次看到这里我也有点难过。
[主播] 我在想我们一路从东非走出来这么多年，难道最终是要面临灭绝的吗？
[主播] 很难过。很不幸的是这一切都是事实。很幸运的是这一切离你还足够远。我说的数万亿年之久。去年中国人的平均寿命是78.1岁。
[主播] 你还有足够多的时间，攀一座山，爱一个人，来自东方甄选的直播间，买一单五常大米，跟爱的人煎一字牛排，吃一碗香喷喷的米饭，平安喜乐的过好你这一生。
[主播] 这就是了。到此结束。大家赶快下单。